sustainability to me is a natural way of
life it's a natural way of using the
given resources on it on both short
medium long time perspective for me it
is there's no alternative to
sustainability the alternative and
sustainability who wants to work with
that so sustainability it's the best way
to use all available resources in in a
way which really mean that resource on
long term will develop be even stronger
and better integrated
I have mixed feelings in the past two to
what we experienced around Cup 15 22
what I've seen happening after cup 15
where people were really enthusiastic up
the cup 15 and right after we almost got
the issue climber was not a hot issue
anymore but almost closed it down set
new issues this is really dangerous path
because the climate change will not not
stop it will accelerate so therefore it
has been discouraging but I have very
optimistic that they even this problem
could be turned into a new opportunity
and I'll do what I can and I know that a
lot of companies and our stakeholders
have used this failure in Copenhagen as
a new driving force for innovating music
innovating the issue rethinking the
issue and then on a longer perspective
we might look better yes this was a temp
situation it was negative but we learned
so much from it that we answer that it
speeded up and and then met our goal and
ensure that we installed a climate
change problem and therefore prepared
paralyzed for next generation
the biggest fear it is that we committed
yet got so discouraged by what has
happened so far that we started climate
change it was an issue political issue
it failed governing forget about the
scientists weren't they couldn't agree
and decent forget about it that
continued as as you know as as as we
used to do and and forget about climate
change so that we have passed a tipping
point and that will not be able to
influence ah the future of our globe the
future of next generation so instead of
being proactive will be reactive and
using while resources to abduct
ourselves to problems we can't solve so
we are on a very slippery road so I feel
that we will we are blindfolded that we
will be blindfolded and and lose
influence on our own destiny
I'll be very optimistic those on the
five years term and a 25 years to him I
believe in that perspective that
business learned the lessons from
Copenhagen and cop15 issues and took the
lead and and develops the Queen
strategies made green gross a winning
strategy and therefore turned the tide
and was the driving force any new entire
tradable evolution was really created
millions of new jobs and a better
quality of life for billions all over
the world so after five years in 2015 we
look back at this point in time and said
yes it was tough times he had climate
problems with financial economic
problems when he we bundled them and
found out that these these issues had
had shared solutions and we developed
this revolution and we already 2005 15
have some of these revolutionaries who
changes and in 2025 we harvest the
fruits from what these fun runners
really performed in 2015 and then
changed the huge deschutes whisk the
biggest risk ever to mankind the child
climate change problems in the biggest
opportunity ever and we will the
historians will look back at this period
and Tyana said that was when we really
developed what could be called the fifth
Industrial Revolution we have had four
previous revolutions they created and
threatened the modern civilization but
the fifth one inaugurated
taking off around 2010 developed it made
it secure and created a new civilization
based on a new quality of life and we
will honor them poop bag and his
drawings will write a lot of fantastic
books about what really happened in
these times of crisis so it is just a
matter of turning risk intelligences and
a difference between a risk and non and
opportunity so soon I discovered and SV
discover it now we have opportunities
were never seen before